japanese carmaker suzuki built its
reputation on the strength of its
compact cars one of the makes best
sellers is the Swift popular since 1983
the model got its most recent facelift
in 2013 though externally similar it has
little in common with the 2005 version
when it comes to technology the car
tester and elite zimmerman wants to know
whether the Suzuki Swift is a long-term
success or in the face of competition
may be losing some of its steam when it
comes to engine options on the Swift
there aren't that many apart from the
sports version every Swift that rolls
off the assembly line is equipped with a
1.2 liter engine an eco plus package
that cuts co2 emissions 299 g/km is
optional it simply drops power output by
a barely noticeable three kilowatts the
top speed remains unchanged at 165 km/h
the Swift's motor doesn't quite cut the
mustard for Andre its performance is all
right but from a purely subjective
standpoint it kicks in too late you need
high revs it's not much fun to drive
fast in the Swift orphan swift red
swimming but super minis are designed to
be practical city cars suzuki itself
calls the Swift a city-run about with
something more at 3 meters 85 in length
and eases into tight parking spaces that
turning radius is just 10.4 meters if
you opt for a swift without the eco plus
package which lowers clearance by 10
millimeters and cuts the turning radius
even further to an impressive 9.6 meters
Andre says the steering is a bit on the
stiff side but it also doesn't give a
lot of feedback one thing that bothered
him a bit at least initially is that the
clutch feels soft but that's not
necessarily a drawback he does like the
smooth shifting the gears slip up and
down almost effortless
he appreciates that very much doesn't
smoke Lisa's ears echoed the Swift has a
distinctive look our test car with the
comfort equipment line features aluminum
rims LED daytime running and fog lights
integrated in the bumper as well as a
light sensor the interior is a bit bland
imma pick up the luggage compartment
offers about 70 liters less space than
competing models Andre says and the sill
height seems to be dictated by a
biblical measure of one cubit rather a
lot but surely less means more space for
the rear seat the big door makes it easy
to get in on Dre finds but to be honest
he says he expected more from the rear
seat given that the trunk is so small
it's okay for short hops because your
knees push against the seat here but you
wouldn't want to sit here long and the
Headroom is surprisingly low priceless
Swift is priced competitively but
overall you get more for your money with
other brands still the Swift has one big
sales edge it's a compact car available
in four-wheel drive which is not
something you find off that's wifey
stepfathers starting at under sixteen
thousand euros in Germany the
four-wheel-drive Swift doesn't even cost
more than the normal model equipped with
a comfort line and even if the
four-wheel drive only comes in the
pared-down Club trim without the light
sensor tinted rear window and aluminum
rims all in all it's a good buy
especially for drivers in suburban or
more rural areas
you
[Music]